Wow
that was pretty great he's good right
mm-hmm best part jetpacks what about the
hidden world where brilliant thinkers
are working together to create an
amazing future hmm how'd argue we're
already living in the future
I mean think about any diner guys got
burgers yeah
burritos jambalaya sure sushi of course
pad thai yep
buttered toast how do they have so many
options
[Music]
this museum is amazing look at where we
are now compared to where they were
we're basically living in the future
I wish I could go back in time and tip
people off about modern inventions hey
everybody this is stuffed crust pizza
oh there's cheese inside the crust come
on oh god don't be so sure
some ideas are just too awesome for
their time like think about it trying to
show our technologies to people back
then you just fry their tiny little ant
brains how would you go and explain
modern medicine
well everything appears to be an order
if there's nothing further I will take
my leave
well I did get this splinter does it
look infected to you know that Hans
gonna have to come off I'm afraid no you
could just give me an antibiotic this
will be a little something for your pain
don't look gross I won't post it one
good thing about living in the 1800s a
hen invented selfies yet say cheese
come on smile okay and just hold it for
20 or 30 minutes maybe the problem is
all the explaining hmm maybe if you
could show somebody something rather
than just telling them about it use it
understand better wrong again see it can
scoop like a spoon but it has the tines
of a fork hmm
I shall call it a foon
[Music]
called dubstep hey everyone we met in
movie huh too bad there isn't a safe
place for new ideas to flourish without
boundaries yeah another world where
inventors can shape the future without
all the idiots man that place to be out
of this world
[Music]